where we left off in the last series of
videos we had the chinese central bank
chinese
central
central bank
that was trying to make sure that the
one does not appreciate too much so the
way they did that is that they bought up
all of the xx dollars using one that
they printed so what they do is they
print one i'll do the one in i'll do it
in this
blue color so they print one
they print one
print
one and then they use that printed one
to buy dollars in the open market and
what that does is it props up the demand
for dollars and keeps the price of one
down so then they get dollars
so they print one
and they buy
they buy dollars
they buy
dollars and as we saw they have to keep
doing this in order to keep the
the the one
in order to keep it deflated or in order
to keep the dollar inflated and this is
so that they can maintain that they're a
favorable balance of trade but as they
do this they're just building the
stockpile of dollar reserves so they are
just building
this stockpile of dollar reserves and as
we mentioned in the last video they're
not just keeping a big vault of
dollar bills there they're going to use
it to buy assets and they're going to
buy liquid and safe assets and the main
asset they're going to buy is u.s
treasury bills so then they take these
dollars
they take these dollars and they buy u.s
treasury bills and let me draw some of
the other actors here because they can
buy it from two separate people there is
the united states government
so there is the u
s
treasury they are going to issue
treasury bills when they essentially
just need to borrow money and then
there's other people that have already
bought treasury bills so let me draw
them over here so then there are other
people there are other people who own
treasury bills so this is someone who
owns a treasury bill right over here
wearing a hat
maybe with a little bit of hair and a
mustache so this is someone who owns a
treasury bill so and just to give a
review when the us government wants to
borrow money people hand the u s
government money so they hand the u s
government
money i'll draw it as a dollar bill
right over there they hand the u s
treasury money and then the u s treasury
gives them an iou
it gives them an iou this iou is what a
treasury bill is
i
o
u and what it entitles the holder of
this piece of paper it allows them to
get interest from the treasury depending
on what type of treasury bill or bond it
will be it'll be over a certain period
of time have a whole video on this
especially the ones where i talk about
the yield curve and then at some future
date the u.s treasury is going to pay
them a larger amount of money than they
put back in so this is just this right
here is a treasury
treasury
treasury bond or bill
t bill if it's a shorter duration
treasury bond if it's a longer duration
so this is a treasury this is a treasury
bond it is a low loan to the us treasury
now the chinese central bank they have
all these excess dollars they can buy
treasuries from either two sources when
the u.s treasury itself needs to raise
funds it will
essentially put these ious for auction
it will sell them to whoever is willing
to take them for the least interest so
let me put it this way
so what they can do is they can give the
money directly to the us treasury when
the u.s treasury puts treasury bills or
treasury bonds up for auction so it can
give the money
directly to the u.s treasury and then
the u.s treasury will give them one of
these
ious us treasury will give them one of
these ious or it could buy it from
someone who already has it out in the
open market or they can go and just go
in the open market this is a very deep
very very liquid open market or they can
give
these people right over here money and
then they would transfer the iou
over to this central bank so what is
happening at the central bank what is
essentially happening here
it's essentially happening is the
chinese central bank printing money to
buy dollars that will then essentially
lend to the us treasury so when this
whole you know looks kind of convoluted
they're doing all this but the essence
of what is happening here
is that the chinese government
you have the chinese central bank
chinese
central bank
central
bank
lending
lending to
u.s
u.s government and it might be buying
other assets but the treasury bonds and
bills are really the main form of liquid
asset they might be buying so what is it
what how does this affect the united
states other than the fact that instead
of owing other investors these these
ious and now owes it to the chinese but
what is the net effect of having this
player out here having this very
significant player out there that is
fairly aggressively
willing to pay for
us government ious us treasuries what is
the effect of that well we saw in the
yield curve video that the more people
willing to give you a loan the lower the
interest rates are going to be and i can
show you a very
simple example of that if i'm looking to
borrow and this is not no longer i'm not
talking about nations i'm just talking
about sal now let's say that i'm
i'm over here
i'm over here and i'm looking to borrow
so i want to
i
want to borrow
i want to borrow
and i say hey who's willing to give me
the best deal on 10 and i'm going to pay
you back next week so you might come
along
you might come along and say
you might come along and say i'll lend
it to you for
10 percent interest over a week so you
can pay me
i'll do it
and you can pay me you can pay me
eleven dollars
eleven dollars next week so this would
essentially be ten percent interest over
the week you give me ten dollars now and
if i agree to you then i'll give you
eleven dollars in a week that would be
ten percent interest but then let's say
i don't know mary comes along
and she says oh i can do better than mr
orange guy over there this is mary
i can do better than mr orange guy over
there
i can you can pay me i'll lend you ten
dollars and you can pay
you can pay me
10.50
next week so notice what happened both
of these people have ten dollars to land
they're looking to get some return on
their ten dollars if he was the only
player here i'd have to go to him and
say okay i'm gonna pay ten percent
interest then she says no no no i also
have ten dollars and gee i would be
happy with just a five percent return
fifty cents off of my ten dollars in one
week that's a good return so right now
i'll look at this person but the more
people that are the more money that's
available to borrow the more competitive
this side of the equation is going to be
and the lower the interest rate i can
get you can imagine even
a third person who says no no wait i've
got ten dollars i've got ten dollars let
me draw this third person
who says i have ten dollars and you know
what it's gonna just be sitting in my
bank account doing nothing unless i lend
it to you you can pay me
you can pay
me
i don't know 10 and 25 cents next week
and then i'm gonna go to this person so
the larger the the number of people
willing to lend to me the lower my
interest rate will be or another way you
could say think of it the larger the
supply of money larger supply
supply
of
money
to be lent
that leads to lower
lower you could view different ways you
could view it as lower borrowing costs
lower borrowing costs
lower borrowing cost which is another
way of just saying
lower interest
lower interest or you could even view it
as cheaper money it costs less to borrow
the money the cost of borrowing money is
the interest
lower
interest now what does that do what does
having lower interest so this is just a
small example with me trying to borrow
ten dollars the more people there are
the more competitive that is the better
interest rate i'll have so you just take
that same notion to kind of a macro
level the u.s government is constantly
borrowing money the more people out
there willing to give it money willing
to buy the us government's ious the
lower the interest rate will be so the
net effect of having this major buyer
this major buyer of user of us
treasuries is that having them out there
accumulating all of these dollars taking
them all out of the foreign exchange
markets and then using them to buy
treasuries it lowers the interest rate
for treasuries
so the chinese so the net effect is
u.s interest u.s treasury has
lower
lower borrowing costs
borrowing costs lower interest so what
does that mean so let's let's make it
very clear
so the chinese
chinese
chinese buy treasuries
by
treasuries
which are essentially loans to the us
government
then the u.s has lower borrowing costs
u.s
has
lower
interest or borrowing cost and i'm
talking about the government right now
borrowing cost and this has several
interesting side effects
this means that it's easier
easier
for the government
to finance deficits
to finance
to finance deficits they don't have to
pay as much as on in interest
to finance deficits so that means that
they can spend more they can
give out more payments to to
u.s citizens or they could lower taxes
either one both of those would lead to
deficits so it's easier
so that they so that the government can
either government can
spend more
spend more or they don't have to raise
taxes or they could
they could lower taxes because they
don't have to spend as much in interest
now the other interesting thing that the
us the treasury borrowing costs go down
that means that the interest rate on
everything goes down this is the
benchmark this is one of the benchmark
interest rates especially and you should
watch the video on the yield curve if
you want to understand more about it and
i know some of you are saying wait
doesn't the fed federal reserve set
interest rates the federal reserve only
sets overnight very short term if you're
going to borrow money overnight in your
bank
that's what the federal reserve says if
people if the u.s government is
borrowing money over 5 or 10 years or 20
years that is set by the market that is
set by a market mechanism very similar
to what i showed just over here so this
is dependent on more capital being there
to be borrowed so this is so 10-year and
15-year and 20-year debt for the u.s
becomes cheaper but this makes all debt
in the u.s cheaper
this makes all debt
all
debt
in
u.s
in u.s cheaper and there's two ways you
can think about why this piece happens
one is just on a very superficial level
people say hey you know someone like
general electric a general electric is
only a little bit more risky than the us
government if the u.s government only
has to pay three percent on its 10-year
on debt that it has to pay back in
10-year maybe general electric should
only have to pay well 30
0.3 percent more than that so that's one
you use the us government as a baseline
and then depending on people's risk they
pay a little higher spread another way
to think about it another way to think
about it is up here the chinese
government is just pouring dollars
either directly to the us government or
into
into the actual into the actual u.s
treasury market so this guy right now he
has more dollars he's not going to use
the treasuries he thinks treasuries are
too expensive which means that their
interest is too low so he's going to
take these dollars he got from the
chinese and he's going to lend it to
someone else that dollar is still there
he'll lend it to general electric or
maybe he's a he's a credit card company
and he'll lend it to the consumer so in
general all debt
all debt in u.s gets cheaper now what's
the net effect of all of these points
what's the net effect of this
all debt in the u.s becomes cheaper
there's just more dollars for loan in
the u.s more dollars that people can
borrow
the government is spending more or the
government will lower taxes what is the
net effect of all of this
well people will either have more money
in their pockets because they've gotten
a government job or they've maybe gotten
some type of entitlement payment or
they're going to have more money in
their pockets because they're paying
lower taxes or they're going to have
more money in their pockets because it's
easier for them to put more debt on
their credit card or to refinance their
mortgage so all of these
all of these
lead to
more cash
in american pockets now that's not
that's obviously not an unambiguously
good thing because not this is all
financed with debt it's not just solid
debt-free cash so more cash
finance in american pockets essentially
finance with debt
financed
with
debt and this debt as you can see it's
either occurring at the credit card
level it could be occurring even at the
corporate debt level it could or that's
occurring indirectly at the government
level but all of this is being enabled
by the fact that china is willing to buy
treasuries which means that china is
really just willing to lend to the us so
what's happening china is lending china
is artificially keeping its currency low
and it's doing that by buying dollars
taking those dollars and invest and
essentially lending them to the united
states and that eventually ends up in
the hands of you not american people and
companies and even the government
and what are they going to do well
they're going to buy cheap chinese
products
that are
artificially cheap because the currency
is lower
so then they will
buy
by chinese and artificially inexpensive
and obviously you know they do have
lower labor costs and all of that but
it's even lower to the american than it
would be if the currency were allowed to
freely float buy chinese products so the
net effect of this entire
this entire scenario that i've been
describing over the last few videos is
that the chinese are essentially lending
money to the americans to then go ahead
and buy more chinese products